I'm not pushing men's narrative I'm
pushing what's true look if a man's a
bum the world will tell him really quick
that he's a bum but some of you female
bumps like the
and you don't know you think you're tens
I mean how many of you guys call I'm not
gonna say your name because I don't want
this Tick Tock to get taken down but a
large celebrity you call her a 10. now
this is the problem if anything I'm more
on women's side because I say we
shouldn't live in delusion but men when
they make a choice and it's a negative
Choice reality hits them hard and they
face the consequences of those in the
world women don't they're just allowed
to live in delusion by steps we're
allowed to live in delusion by other
women and it's not kind it's not honest
and at least they'll come here and tell
you what's true